hello and welcome to this video playing
pro low here from france french flag at
least yep yeah i haven't done any videos
yesterday unfortunately and this is also
on a little bit late yeah I simply
didn't manage to produce enough things
and my weekend was completely packed
with the over the board chess playing a
blitz team event and um a regular second
bulls the event on the Sunday so I
couldn't really get to get the usual
pack of videos on the road on time so
late recording but it is a new bunch of
three minute games here on the on the
Tuesday okay um we have a sloth defense
and the line where why does some
slightly more comfortable and
threatening be five no yes OE he does
move the rook you know the interesting
question is he has already strengthened
my pawn structure here so i mean i can
even invest this time here to place the
night over 285 because the counter play
with a five or g5 here is not as um as
worrisome now I expect g5 now g5 Bishop
g3 Bishop g7 but ok the Knight a5 is
already pretty bad okay not sure Knight
a5 is a very big problem
okay 795 yeah so it can takes you three
but i'll i'll have the whole Queen cider
so Bishop a six or look a six or a
success looking a little bit more
powerful yeah so we have b5 you will
take with the night I guess what's the
big deal here write a five if is also
good just attack the pond
not quite clear how we can defend it
Bishop d7 desribe 7 and now we cannot
cancel anymore pretty bad position
Bishop a6 as also also a threat yeah
that whole line queen bee three queen
bee six it's not particularly
comfortable for black and one additional
an accurate move can easily cost the
game in your form below 2500 again play
down a game in my monday live show that
got lost ok yeah I guess grabbing
material is it bad it's got this FY idea
but I'll just win stuff ok um Bishop's
is seven wins the exchange I think it's
no reason not to
okay and now the abbey should be seven
as possible just grab more material not
be 50 k 8 I don't mind to trade
before yeah probably castle nope they're
just castle check check check there's a
416 check black resigns yeah that whole
opening line in a little bit Queen B 6 a
slightly questionable and far more
reliable is to take on c4 or play six
notes are the most reliable moves yeah
here this is still not terrible for
black but you have to be always quite
cautious in this structure white has
those ideas like be for Bishop f4 like
played in the game and I think what he
did now this quickly night you form and
training I think this is a mistake it
strengthens my pawn center on my pawn
wedge him and it's gone to play if there
is none then she simply has no counter
play in this position the 63 threatening
be five now so I moves the rook and now
i'm already quite substantially better
the night maneuver is good sea forts
also in good move both cases with a with
a very nice advantage but here yes to he
has to do something now quickly p.m. and
not to just wait h6 is too low it's too
slow I think and this it would have been
interesting to maybe play f6 and and
shoot for an e5 something like this I
still sorry this was the wrong
still have some pressure but this is not
so bad for black I mean I think white is
better but it's nothing too serious but
now it gets very difficult prevent 95 or
595 it's probably already already over
and there is this additional problem
probably with these six I know that you
can actually take but I have f4 and yeah
now that's not a good line it's another
good variation yeah here I'm just I'm
just winning the queenside you cannot
cancel that's the exchange I know you
just have to pick up pick up things
check check you know it's Jack's
immediately is also show a limit that
also wins the house yeah that opening
line is a little bit questionable and
then some additional mistake can can
spell disaster ok I hope you enjoyed the
video thanks for watching